Franck qui dit tout de suite
qu'effectivement elle avait eu des
relations sexuelles avec Hourdin kourdin
était pas d'accord que ça lui faisait
mal comble de l'horreur Franck explique
que ces scènes de viol auraient beaucoup
amusé alto Bella elle les aurait même
fait filmer
le 29 septembre 2003 à
Verdun-sur-Garonne petite ville à 40 km
de Toulouse les gendarmes vont arriver
un témoin qui se présente spontanément à
leur brigade
ce témoin veut soulager sa conscience
efface aux gendarmes médusés il fait un
incroyable récit on a une personne qui
se présente au bureau de la jambe et de
Verdun-sur-Garonne qui demande à parler
au chef Sarda qui qui vient signaler des
cette personne a des révélations à faire
et souhaite garder l'anonymat cette
personne a été entendue sous X donc sans
nom sans prénom sur le sur l'audition ni
adresse numéro de téléphone fais-moi
pour elle et elle désire donner ses
renseignements à ce qu'elle pense être
des gens pouvant travailler et puis
enquêter là-dessus l'individu relate des
faits qui se serait passé dans un
village voisin
des faits d'une gravité extrême
[Musique]
cet individu les informe de ce qu'il y
aurait-tu un meurtre dans une auberge
l'Auberge du thaï à Aucamville
un homme aurait été pendant des années
séquestré violet et aurait fini par
mourir dans des circonstances
indéterminées
donne ce qu'il sait et il donne
également un nom un nom et un prénom il
l'évoque un George ourdin il sait pas
comment ça s'écrit
le témoin ne s'est pas orthographié le
nom de la victime mais il donne une
description physique de ce George ourdin
il aurait près de 60 ans petit
1m65 environ maigre ce témoin anonyme
donne des précisions sur ce qui se
serait passé derrière les murs de
l'Auberge du thaï des choses à peine
croyable ce personne donc nous dit
qu'elle a pris que Georges ourdin au
cours d'une soirée sadomasochiste a été
tué
[Musique]
que son corps a été donné au cochon pour
qu'il soit dévoré donc disparaître et
que les restes de son corps ont donc été
ensuite jetés dans un puits
on est en 2003 et l'indique
estime
les faits à environ 6 ans auparavant
donc on arrive en 1990
d'après l'informateur se meurtre
particulièrement sordide ce serait
produit dans cette paisible auberge de
campagne
ce témoignage pourrait paraître
fantaisiste pourtant il va être pris au
sérieux par les gendarmes peu habitués à
traiter des crimes de sang il se trouve
qu'on est à Verdun-sur-Garonne qu'ils ne
sont pas débordés par les affaires
criminelles et donc ils ont le temps de
gérer ce type d'information ce type de
dossier l'adjudant Sarda se met au
travail mais d'emblée
va être compliqué
il est clair que les choses soient
d'aboutir étaient faibles on sait
traditionnellement que plus une enquête
démarre longtemps après la commission
des faits moins de la de chance aboutir
les gendarmes n'ont que peu d'éléments
un nom écrit en phonétique George ourdin
et un lieu
l'auberge ou le crime s'est déroulé un
restaurant qui va immédiatement faire
l'objet de toutes les attentions
l'auberge se situe à environ 4500 mètres
de centre-ville du centre du village de
ville qui est une petite bourgade
c'était la Bonne Auberge franchouillarde
dans lequel on mangeait bien on buvait
bien seulement l'établissement est fermé
depuis quatre ans mais la famille
propriétaire de l'auberge y vit toujours
l'Auberge du thaï est tenue par un
couple elle est italienne alto Bella
capelleri et son mari Armand laveront
qui est décédé depuis
l'italienne on la surnomme l'italienne
et très peu impliquée dans la vie du
village en fait les gens la connaissent
pas bien
chaque fois c'est les mêmes
renseignements on mange bien mais alto
Bella est bizarre les rumeurs vont bon
train dans le village au sujet de la
propriétaire de l'auberge et des soirées
très spéciales qu'elle organise le soir
déjà y aller elle faisait des soirées
elle se mettait toute nue sur la table
et elle dansait toute nue on évoquait
disons quelques dérapages d'ordre sexuel
la rumeur disait que de toute façon
certaines soirées y étaient plus ou
moins osé
la rumeur dit même qu'elle offrait sa
fille qui est sourde et muettes
à son représentant de champagne pour
avoir quelques réductions sur le montant
des factures
voilà ça a l'air d'être un une maison
close mais un endroit où on s'amuse en
tout cas
alors c'est très délicat parce que d'un
côté on bâtit pas une enquête sur des
sur des rumeurs de notre côté quand on
enquête sur des faits vieux de disand
d'âge j'allais dire on prend tout ce qui
vient on prend tout ce qui vient et
après on essaie méthodiquement de faire
le tri de voir ce qui peut reposer sur
du sérieux et de voir ce qui relève de
la rumeur pur et simple qui restera à
l'état de rumeur plus récente à
Verdun-sur-Garonne les gendarmes sont
d'autant plus prudents que la patronne
altobe la capellerie n'a jamais eu
affaire à la justice et qu'aucune
plainte n'a été déposée contre
l'établissement
quelqu'un chercherait-il à se venger de
la propriétaire de l'auberge les
gendarmes seraient-ils sur une fausse
piste que se passe-t-il réellement à
l'auberge du thaï les gendarmes n'en
n'ont pas la moindre idée
il décide alors de vérifier la
configuration des lieux car selon le
témoin le corps aurait été jeté au
cochon et dans un puits
pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons il ne
se présente pas à la porte de l'auberge
on fait survole en hélicoptère qui nous
confirme bien l'existence de bâtiment
pouvoir recevoir des animaux comme des
cochons ou autre on a une confirmation
qu'il y a bien un puits juste devant la
propriété
selon l'informateur anonyme Georges
Hourdin la victime présumée aurait
séjourné un certain temps à l'auberge
alors discrètement les gendarmes
décident d'aller poser quelques
questions aux mers du village
[Musique]
ils vont commencer leur enquête parler à
la mairie pour essayer de savoir s'il y
avait un type qui correspondrait ou qui
aurait pu correspondre à ce nom de
Georges Jourdain
et là le maire se souvient d'un vague
SDF qui est resté là quelques quelques
années qu'il a peu vu les 10 qu'il a vu
passer la sanction reprise que bon voilà
c'est pas quelqu'un qui l'a vu souvent
mais en tout cas il a vu mais on n'a pas
de renseignement plus avant il est il
est a priori bien logé chez altomella
Capellen donc voilà les éléments qui
nous apportent donc déjà nous ça nous
prouve que cet individu a habité à
Aucamville ou du moins il est passé
[Applaudissements]
les gendarmes ont donc la certitude que
George ourdin est passé à Aucamville
mais rien ne prouve qu'il soit mort à
l'auberge du village d'autant qu'aucun
Hourdain n'a été porté disparu en France
les enquêteurs se lancent alors dans un
travail titanesque
[Musique]
donc les gendarmes vont puiser chercher
à travers tous les fichiers
administratifs et ils vont ratisser
extrêmement large auprès de toutes les
administrations ils envoient des
réquisitions un tour de bras et un peu
partout en France sur toutes les CPAM
sur tous les départements sur toutes les
sécurités sociales donc c'est quelque
chose d'énorme alors là on n'est pas on
n'est pas à NCIS ou FBI porté disparu
les renseignements mettent un temps fou
à remonter d'abord parce que c'est des
fichiers manuels donc il faut qu'il y
ait un type qui qui fouille à la lettre
O à la lettre H puisque on sait pas
comment ça s'écrit ourdin c'est avec un
h avec un o on n'en sait rien
beaucoup d'organismes nous répondent que
faute de date de naissance et de lieu de
naissance ne peuvent nous fournir plus
de plus d'informations les gendarmes
épluche des milliers de réponses et au
bout de deux mois le travail finit par
payer
dans le fichier des personnes
recherchées un George ourdin avec un H
est répertorié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc on a un changement qui cherchait
par la gendarmerie dans le 45 les
gendarmes de Verdun-sur-Garonne se
procurent une photo de ce George ourdin
on reçoit la photographie qu'on présente
à ce témoin de tout début de l'enquête
[Musique]
ce témoin nous dit non ce n'est pas jour
aujourd'hui
cette première piste s'effondre
l'enquête repart à zéro mais les
gendarmes sans tête
[Musique]
on arrive à recevoir deux réponses de la
Mairie de Paris qui nous donne deux
identités dans le genre Jourdain qui
sont nés à 3 ou 4 jours d'intervalle
dans deux arrondissements différents
[Musique]
qui ont exactement la même orthographe
le premier Georges Hourdin est toujours
en vie marié des enfants
donc celui là on le met de côté ça nous
ferme une porte de l'enquête et en
enquête enfin sur le jour Jourdain qui
nous intéresse donc
ils vont s'intéresser à celui-là et là
ce coup-ci ils ont une date de naissance
et donc ça va leur permettre d'affiner
leur recherche dans les différents
fichiers il a une soixantaine d'années
donc ça pourrait coller par rapport aux
informations qu'il détiennent par
ailleurs et l'homme a déjà fait parler
de lui par le passé dans plusieurs
villes de France
on retrouve trace de George Jourdain par
deux fois une première fois pour une
hospitalisation d'office
vraisemblablement à un état alcoolique
dans un établissement spécialisé à
Bar-le-Duc et la seconde fois pour
livrer ce public et les manifeste
enregistré par le commissariat de police
de Metz on a une condamnation pour des
faits d'exhibition en région parisienne
mais qu'il a dit il y a longtemps donc
pas de photographie pas de prise
empreintes ce genre Jourdain intéresse
les gendarmes d'autant qu'ils vont
trouver une trace d'un dépôt à Nîmes
en 1975 ce George ourdin a déposé une
modeste somme de 10 francs dans une
banque de Nîmes les gendarmes cernent
mieux maintenant cet homme il aurait une
soixantaine d'années un profil de SDF en
tout cas quelqu'un de modeste
reste à savoir si aujourd'hui cet homme
est mort et les enquêteurs vont avoir le
plus grand mal à le déterminer
on retrouve que la sœur
très peu de contact depuis très
longtemps et elle ne peut nous donner
aucun renseignement sur le parcours de
vie de son frère Jean Jourdain est né
d'une fratrie de 6 ou 7 enfants et après
avoir fait la guerre d'Algérie il a
rompu tout lien avec sa famille depuis
une trentaine d'années aucune
administration en France ou à l'étranger
ou un territoire d'outre-mer me l'a
déclaré des CD ça me traite aurait dû
être versée à partir de 1997 cela ne l'a
pas été fait
George ourdin aurait 66 ans voici la
seule photo qui existe de lui c'était
dans les années 50
[Musique]
ILOM n'a pas touché sa retraite cela
pourrait bien confirmer l'hypothèse de
sa mort mais dans ce cas là pourquoi
personne n'a déclaré son décès
[Musique]
le 12 mars 2004 après 6 mois d'enquête
rebondissements dans les registres d'un
hôpital de Toulouse les gendarmes
découvrent une information capitale
c'était l'hôpital de Rangueil pour une
hospitalisation sans aucune autre
explication
datant de 1988 et qui localisait George
Jourdain chez l'Aveyron Isabelle
l'Auberge du thaï à aucamille
Isabelle laveron le nom des pouces
d'altober la capellerie George ourdin
est donc bien passé à l'auberge du thaï
les gendarmes pensent avoir maintenant
tous les éléments pour confirmer le
témoignage du début d'enquête
George Jourdain SDF oui il est venu
Aucamville oui il était chez Isabelle
laveron oui mais que s'est-il réellement
passé
pourquoi George Jourdain aurait-il été
tué pour avancer les gendarmes tentent
de mieux cerner les habitants de
l'auberge
en réalité villa alto Bella l'italienne
son mari est mort depuis sa fille sourde
muette son gendre qui est également
atteint de la même maladie
et puis il y a ces deux fils qui
grenouillent autour qui viennent qui
viennent pas qui passent qui restent qui
s'en vont enfin en tout cas ils sont pas
loin et puis un espèce d'ouvriers
agricole ils appellent Franck Hanbal
le 25 mai 2004 à 6h du matin pour éviter
les fuites tout le monde est interpellé
en même temps Franck l'ouvrier agricole
altobella capellerie l'aubergiste
italienne
l'un de ses fils Claude
[Musique]
l'opération se passe sans difficulté
immédiatement les gendarmes
perquisitionnent l'auberge et ses
terrains alentours à la recherche de
preuve matérielles si Georges ourdin a
bien été tué ici il doit forcément
rester des traces ils font appel à
l'abrigade cynophile ce sont des chiens
qui sont spécialisés dans la recherche
de cadavres et d'ossement et nous avons
donc fait ratisser l'ensemble des
terrains aux alentours de l'auberge
la perquisition a été fait dans tout le
domaine
dans toute la bâtisse dans toutes les
dépendances dans la porcherie des
photons ont été faites après de longues
heures de recherche les gendarmes se
rendent à l'évidence
la propriété immense on y travaille deux
jours d'affilée les chiens ne
prouveraient du tout les recherches ne
donnent rien même dans le puits ou
d'après l'informateur les restes du
corps auraient été jetés
les gendarmes sont dans une situation
délicate car sans preuve matérielle ils
n'ont plus qu'une seule solution obtenir
des aveux
où il faut la jouer fine parce qu'il y a
la garde à vue c'est pas extensible et
ils ont 48 heures pour essayer de faire
craquer soit la belle italienne soit ses
enfants soit le simplet du village mais
en tout cas il faut que ça faut que ça
vienne faut que ça craque
quand les gendarmes donnent le motif de
leur garde à vue à savoir la mort de
George ourdin la réaction est unanime
tout son premier jour Jourdain
et apparemment personne ne sait qu'il
est mort
devant les enquêteurs altobella
cappelleri petite femme de 64 ans
s'affiche d'emblée comme autoritaire sur
d'elle
c'est une femme donc d'une certaine âge
qui est plutôt en rondeur
après il faut croiser son regard il faut
croiser son regard et là on sent qu'on a
affaire à quelqu'un qui a une volonté
extrêmement ferme quelqu'un qui est une
maîtresse femme si l'on peut dire
quelqu'un qui est en position
psychologique de supériorité par rapport
aux gens qui l'entourent alto Bella à la
gendarmerie se croit à l'auberge c'est
elle qui commande elle veut diriger elle
veut faire à sa manière elle a essayé
d'avoir une emprise sur le gendarme qui
était en charge de sa garde à vue et de
l'auditionner
bon elle a trouvé elle a trouvé forte
partie elle a trouvé à qui à faire mais
elle a essayé de lui contraindre lui
imposer sa manière de voir les choses et
puis son bon vouloir et la patronne de
l'auberge denier tout implication dans
la disparition de Georges Jourdain
son système de défense consiste à tout
nier c'est à dire qu'elle dit je ne vois
même pas de quoi il s'agit je vois pas
que je fais ici moi je connais
l'individu dont vous me parlez
Hourdin je l'ai il est venu souvent à la
maison mais il est parti depuis
longtemps il est parti de son plein gré
je ne sais pas où il est c'était froid
c'était calculateur c'était
on sentait derrière la
le cerveau froid l'analyse froide qui
disait ne parle pas ne parle pas ne dit
rien
quand l'avez-vous vu pour la dernière
fois
cela devait être en 1993 il m'a dit
qu'il partait pour l'Allemagne en
partant il m'a fauché une bouteille
d'Armagnac
les heures d'interrogatoire des fils les
gendarmes ont la conviction caltobella
leur manque
dans le bureau d'à côté Franck l'ouvrier
agricole qui traînait souvent à
l'auberge et que tout le monde qualifie
de simplet raconte comment il a connu
alto Bella c'était il y a très longtemps
donc il raconte qu'à huit ans il passait
là le long du chemin et puis
s'intéresser un petit peu à l'auberge à
ce qui se passait regarder par la haie
et c'est là quand on est là il a dit
m'écoutante regarde tu peux rester tu
accueillis je te donne à manger parce
que ça bannière de faire de mettre les
gens en confiance je te donne à manger
tu pourras rester puis petit à petit il
est revenu il est revenu il est revenu
puis à
devenu majeur il a commencé à habiter là
il vient à l'auberge il fait des menus
travaux du coup on lui donne à manger on
lui donne à boire et à un moment donné
il va avoir des relations sexuelles
pendant deux ans avec cette dame
là où les choses vont se gâter c'est
quand il va s'apercevoir peu à peu
qu'elle est alcoolique manipulatrice et
il va commencer en avoir peur
Franck raconte kaltobella le terrorisait
les gendarmes lui demandent si la connu
George Jourdain Franck répond que oui il
se souvient même de son arrivée à
l'auberge
c'est quelqu'un qui vole un jour pousser
la porte de l'auberge du Teil pour
Pokémon à manger tout simplement et à
qui elle tombait la capellerie va
proposer le gîte et le couvert en
échange de travaux il semble qu'au début
les choses ne se soient pas forcément
mal passé et progressivement elles ont
dégénéré et au fur et à mesure puis va
être complètement sous l'emprise de
cette femme qui va le battre lorsqu'il
obéit pas c'était son esclave elle le
lavait nu en plein hiver dans la course
ou des jets d'eau froide qu'elles le
battait de différentes manières avec
différents objets
voilà qu'elle lui faisait faire tous ses
basses tâches
jour Jourdain l'homme a tout faire celui
qui était régulièrement battu celui à
qui on lui faisait faire n'importe quoi
qui vivait comme une bête et qu'elle
enfermait dans la petite buanderie
derrière les salles de restaurant
quand je Hourdin essaiera à au moins
deux ou trois reprises de fuir l'auberge
chaque fois alto la capellerie envers
son mari récupérer George ourdin et le
ramener contraint à forcer à l'auberge
un esclave des temps modernes
en plus de d'être frappé en plus d'être
souillé
c'est il n'a aucune vie ce n'est plus un
être humain pour le tomber là
c'est un souffle dans son récit Franck
va même plus loin georges ourdin était
non seulement tenu en esclavage mais
l'ouvrier agricole avoue avoir violé à
plusieurs reprises le SDF sous l'oeil
daltobella c'est elle qui dirige c'est
elle qui décide du moment où vont se
dérouler donc c'est ses actes et qui
indiquent comment ils vont se dérouler
Franck il dit tout de suite
qu'effectivement il avait eu des
relations sexuelles avec Urda que ourdin
était pas d'accord que ça lui faisait
mal
[Musique]
George était frappé s'il ne s'exécutait
pas
pour ma part elle me grondait si je
n'obéissais pas
dans le dos ça fait froid dans le dos ce
que lui fait subir cette femme parce que
ben oui les actes sont commis par Franck
mais sous la direction dans tombola
comble de l'horreur Franck explique que
ces scènes de viol auraient beaucoup
amusé à tomber là elle les aurait même
fait filmer mais lorsqu'on balle nous
refusera ne voudra pas violer genre
Jourdain elle lui menacera de les
diffuser cette cassette au membre de sa
famille qui demeure sur le village elle
menace tout le monde en fait donc tout
le monde est son jouet et le plus faible
de ses jouets c'est finalement Georges
a priori le témoignage de Frank paraît
sincère
[Musique]
on ne sent pas une once de mensonges
dans ses propos de par la faiblesse
intellectuelle de Frank handball
lorsqu'il nous raconte tout ça on sait
qu'il peut pas mentir il ne peut pas
mentir il donne des détails il raconte
la souffrance de George Jourdain il
rencontre le chatage qu'il subit lui
[Musique]
sur la mort de George Franck ne sait
rien il confirme les dires d'altobella
Georges est partie du jour au lendemain
sans plus d'explications
[Musique]
à la gendarmerie de Verdun-sur-Garonne
les heures passent mais toujours pas la
moindre preuve de la mort de George
Jourdain
les enquêteurs interrogent Claude le
fils aîné dalto Bella un solide gaillard
d'un mètre 90 manifestement l'homme a
beaucoup de choses sur la conscience
on a à peine le temps de poser la
question qu'on a la réponse
et des mouvements caractéristiques d'une
personne qui est qui avait besoin de
parler mais qui a aussi peur d'alto
Bella
on ne peut pas énoncer le nom de sa mère
sans qu'il regarde ses pieds
malgré la corpulence de l'individu on
sent que
sa mère c'est quelque chose qu'il ne
faut pas toucher mais pas dans le sens
de l'amour mais dans le sens de la peur
Claude confirme le récit de France
Georges ourdin a vécu 6 ans à l'auberge
du thaï lui aussi a tout vu c'est une
violence quotidienne des coups des gifs
des coups de poing des humiliations des
viols même mais quotidiennement mais
Claude ne s'arrête pas là il dit savoir
ce qui est arrivé à Georges
cela ce serait passé un soir sa mère
leur est appelée et elle lui aurait
demandé de la rejoindre d'urgence à
l'auberge voici ce qu'il raconte il
arrive à l'auberge du thaï et découvre
George Jourdain allongé par terre mort
sa mère lui dit que elle l'a tué Georges
[Musique]
jamais su exactement comment la victime
était décédée il n'a jamais eu
d'explication là-dessus mais il savait
que à cause de tous les coups donnés un
jour ça finirait comme ça
les gendarmes comprennent qu'il n'y a
pas de mobile dans cette sortie
d'affaires
puis il est probablement mort des
sévices qu'il a subi probablement mort
de coup qu'il a pu recevoir à ce
moment-là
c'est genre je crois c'est la
serpillière il est par terre on s'en
occupe pas forcément quelques heures
après on a besoin qu'il fasse quelque
chose ou qui ramasse un objet qui range
etc puis là on s'aperçoit que Georges il
est mort tout simplement quoi peut-être
qu'on lui met un petit coup de pied pour
le secouer voir si il bouge
[Musique]
personne ne prévient ni secours ni genre
ni police ni pompier ni s'annule
alto Bella aurait alors ordonné à Claude
son fils et à son mari de se débarrasser
du cadavre
[Musique]
ils vont décider sur les ordres de sa
mère d'amener le corps dans la porcherie
pensant naïvement que les cochons
allaient manger George Jourdain
seulement le plan de l'aubergine
italienne ne se serait pas déroulée
comme prévu Claude continue son récit le
lendemain matin lorsqu'il se rendent à
la porcherie les propriétaires de
l'auberge doivent se rendre à l'évidence
les cochons n'ont pas touché au corps de
Georges son cadavre est intacte et pour
cause Claude le fils pris de scrupules a
pris quelques dispositions on ne peut
pas vivre toutes ces années sans avoir
un temps soit peu de sentiments
d'affection pour celui qui est là donc
sur la chaîne énormément Claude de voir
le corps de Georges Bourdin mangeait par
tes cochons donc en cachette il va
nourrir les cochons pour que ceci
n'ayant pas faim ne mange pas le corps
de George Jourdain
il revient à l'auberge du thaï et sa
mère lui dit que les cochons ne touchant
pas le corps de Georges Jourdain il faut
le mettre dans le puisard
[Musique]
il le met dans le puisard et remettre la
dalle en béton qui ferme le puisard et
il rentre chez lui avec ordre de ne
parler de ça à personne
donc Claude trois mois plus tard sa mère
lui aurait ordonné de récupérer le corps
de George dans le puisard son but le
faire disparaître définitivement
là encore il est obligé à sa mère il
vient et avec sa mère et son beau-père
Armand il récupère le corps dans le
puisard
et le dépose à l'intérieur de l'auberge
à l'intérieur de l'auberge il y a un
grand hêtre de cheminée et là sa mère
lui dit on va le cramer
et je t'appellerai pour jeter les
sangles le cadavre de George ourdin
aurait alors brûlé toute la nuit le
lendemain matin elle donne sac poubelle
à Claude son fils lui dit maintenant tu
vas le jeter dans une poubelle et il se
rend à Toulouse il va le jeter dans une
poubelle
municipale à sur Toulouse
[Musique]
enfin c'est pas imaginable c'est on voit
ça que dans les films
les gendarmes sont sidérés par le récit
du fils d'altobella qui semble
totalement sincère
tous respirent la vérité dans ce qu'il
dit on voit qu'il revit des moments on
voit qu'il revit les visions qu'il a eu
et on sent quelqu'un qui dit la vérité
on a aucun doute à aucun moment sur ce
qui raconte le récit de Claude ne
s'arrête pas là grâce à lui les
gendarmes en apprennent un peu plus sur
la personnalité d'altobella une mère
odieuse et tyrannique
c'était des enfants battus mais pour lui
c'était un quotidien comme pour George
Jourdain d'ailleurs c'est à dire que
c'est la seule expression dans ce milieu
là c'était la violence alors que Bruno
était âgé de quelques années pour le
punir d'avoir fait au lit alto Bella
cappelleri va lui brûler le sexe avec
une cigarette
pour une broutille un couvercle tombé à
table ou quelque chose de cet ordre là
et bien il passera une nuit dehors nu en
plein hiver alto Bella bon c'était à la
fois la marara la matrone c'était le
tirant
[Musique]
je crois qu'il est sincère quand il dit
qu'il avait peur de sa mère claude était
vraiment sous l'influence de sa mère et
était dans l'incapacité totale de réagir
ou de se rebeller les déclarations de
Franck l'ouvrier agricole et de Claude
le fils d'altobella Concorde selon eux
l'aubergine italienne n'aurait pas
hésité à tuer Georges ourdin son esclave
domestique et sexuel mais ont-ils dit la
vérité encore faut-il pouvoir le prouver
et pour les gendarmes les choses
s'annoncent beaucoup plus compliquées
que prévu
ils le savent sans aucune preuve
matérielle il sera difficile de faire
condamner altobe la capellerie il décide
alors de passer l'auberge au crible
notamment le vestibule ou dormait
Georges
lorsque les techniciens passent le
bluestin à cet endroit là on retrouve du
son
ces traces de sang sont vieilles elles
ont été lavées pour une grande partie et
altérer on ne pourra pas trouver d'ADN
sur ces traces de sang
[Musique]
on trouve des traces de sang imprégnées
dans le béton de la porcherie mais ce ne
sont pas des éléments matériels
réfutables ce sang ne nous amène pas à
Jourdain
n'a pas pu déterminer si s'agissait du
sang de roudain ou s'il s'agissait du
sang d'animaux c'était pas possible
c'était trop ancien mais on retrouve du
sang il n'y a aucune élément matériel il
réfutable on ne trouve jamais cette
cassette vidéo où on voit en bas le
violet genre Jourdain alors qui croire
qui ment est-ce que George Jourdain a
vraiment vécu ce calvaire les gendarmes
n'ont aucune preuve matérielle
heureusement ils vont bientôt bénéficier
d'une aide inespérée
[Musique]
et ce coup de main va venir de Martine
la fille sourde et muettes d'altobella
remettent au gendarmes une cassette
vidéo de fête de famille
les gendarmes la visionnent et voici les
images qu'il découvre alors
on voit à deux ou trois reprises George
ourdin la première à tablée une personne
qui a l'air fatiguée et un petit peu
attaqué par l'alcool mais qui présente
bien
[Musique]
sur la seconde partie de la vidéo on
voit une personne qui est blessée à
l'oreille qui a un gros pansement une
personne qui a l'air fatiguée
usé
frappé et présente quelques bleus et
quelqu'un qui me pose au niveau du
visage c'est l'ombre d'un être humain
si oui elle l'a complètement fait un
esclave un jouet et puis comme on fait
avec un jouet quand on en a marre on
sentait le faire on le jette au rebu
quoi tout simplement les gendarmes
décident de confronter alto Bella à ses
accusateurs Frank et Claude sont alors
terrorisés
et là à la première question alto Bella
prend la parole
et dès qu'un des deux vont répondre un
regard suffit de faire taire ou aller
faire regarder ses chaussures et c'est
la première fois où on a été amené à
mettre une couverture les séparants car
ils avaient peur de son regard
face à son fils face à Franck alto Bella
conserve sa ligne de défense
[Musique]
l'ensemble des déclarations qui sont
faites à son encontre son mensongeur et
elle restera dans sa version monsieur
Hourdin a quitté de son plein gré
l'Auberge du thaï pour elle tout est
complot c'est contre elle et en fait se
considère comme la victime
[Musique]
pas de corps pas de trace matériel six
ans pour dénoncer un meurtre et si tout
cela n'était effectivement qu'un complot
contre alto Bella
un nouvel élément va venir éclairer la
justice
janvier 2005 après 16 mois d'enquête à
force de recoupement les gendarmes ont
un nouvel élément concret à fournir à la
juge d'instruction
la sécurité sociale de Montauban leur
apprend que George ourdin percevais une
pension de 3000 francs jusqu'en 1997
et il était domicilié chez Isabelle
Laveyron c'est-à-dire altobella
cabelleri
pourtant l'aubergiste a toujours déclaré
que George était parti de l'auberge 4
ans plus tôt en 1993 dans le bureau de
la juge d'instruction alto Bella est
bien obligé de s'expliquer
à partir de là évidemment la juge va
mettre l'italienne face à ses
responsabilités
judiciaires en disant mais comment se
fait-il que vous inquiétiez sa pension
s'il est vivant et s'il est plus avec
vous moi je suis derrière elle elle a
des mouvements d'épaule elle a des
mouvements de tête on sent la personne
qui est pas bien et qui va parler face à
ça elle est obligé de convenir que
George
ourdin est resté à l'auberge
et y est décédé
et qu'effectivement c'est elle qui a
perçu la pension et non plus genre
Jourdain jusqu'au 60 ans de celui-ci
altobella vient de craquer George
Jourdain et bien mort seulement la
restauratrice explique qu'elle n'aurait
rien à voir dans sa disparition
[Musique]
elle dit qu'en fait George est bien
moral Auberge Du taille mais c'est pas
elle ne l'a pas frappée au contraire
elle va donner une toute autre version
des faits
cela se serait passé un soir de juillet
1992 alto Bella capellerie raconte
qu'elle était à l'auberge avec son mari
Armand quand sa belle-mère qui dormait
dans une chambre et s'est mise à crier
Armand son mari a accouru dans sa
chambre son mari aurait surpris George
ourdin dans la chambre de la mer de
Madame laveron maire
serait entré en colère aurait poursuivi
George Jourdain qui aurait trébuché
contre la margelle de la piscine et
aurait serait tombé sur la tête et
aurait eu une blessure à la tête qui
aurait entraîné son décès
le reste de la faire du moment où George
a tapé la rebord de la piscine
[Musique]
je suis
on est d'accord avec tout le monde c'est
à dire dans un premier temps on dépose
le corps dans la Porsche riz et ensuite
on décide de le mettre dans la fosse
elle reconnaît ensuite que quelques mois
plus tard
ils auraient choisi de ressortir le
corps de la fosse et de procéder donc à
son à sacrémation dans la cheminée de
l'auberge et donc on sait que le corps
va brûler une une nuit entière
elle tombait la capelleri qui à ce
moment-là reconnaît avoir voulu faire
disparaître le corps précisera que son
mari décédé depuis lors entretenait la
combustion en versant de la graisse de
canard sur le cadavre en train de brûler
on a donc aucune trace du corps de
George woderm on est chez les fous on
est chez les monstres
ce détail est surnaturel
devant la juge d'instruction alto Bela
explique qu'elle n'aurait été que témoin
du drame elle n'aurait rien fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait en fait dans
cette histoire elle charge son mari qui
est décédé donc qui est hors d'atteinte
sur un plan judiciaire tout ce qui est
grave c'est le mari qui l'a fait le mari
est mort les enquêteurs se renseignent
sur la personnalité du mari d'altobella
cette apparemment un homme très soumis
comme du reste tous les hommes qui
entourent l'italienne
[Musique]
c'est un pauvre homme c'est un homme
battu
et qui jamais n'aurait fait de mal à
Jourdain mais qui par contre lui a
souvent été frappé
par sa femme
sa femme lui a même planté des coups de
couteau dans les fesses lui courir après
avec un couteau
de nombreux épisodes de nombreux
témoignages montrant qu'il y avait une
violence exercée de Madame sur monsieur
entre autres madame capelleri a eu pour
amant un représentant de commerce et que
quand celui-ci couché à l'auberge et
bien madame cappelleri taper du point le
matin contre la le mur de la chambre et
son mari qui était dans la pièce
atomante venait servir le petit déjeuner
au lit à son épouse et à la main de
celle-ci
mais pour Gilbert Collard l'avocat
daltobella cappelleri le caractère
effacé du mari ne le disculpe pas pour
autant
on peut avoir l'air très soumis dans la
vie de tous les jours et puis d'un seul
coup se révéler très violent et
parfaitement autoritaire mais cet
argument
dans le contexte apporté c'était elle
qui devait décider ça ne pouvait pas
être lui
[Musique]
alto Bella capellerie reconnaît bien que
George Jourdain est mort à l'auberge
mais elle n'y est pour rien du tout tout
cela est la faute de son mari
la version d'altobella ne semble pas
satisfaisante elle ne colle pas au
constatation des gendarmes
alto dit qu'il est mort au bord de la
piscine ce n'est pas corroboré parce que
le groupe de techniciens en
investigation criminelle de Bordeaux
trouve des traces de sang dans le
vestibule et non pas sur le bord de la
piscine genre Jourdain semble être
décédé dans le vestibule ce qui prouve
encore kalobella ment
[Musique]
pour la juge les choses sont claires
même si alto Belani George Jourdain a
été séquestré maltraité abusé
sexuellement pendant des années à
l'auberge il a été frappé à mort et
c'est altobella qui a organisé la
disparition du cadavre la porcherie puis
le puisard et enfin la cheminée de
l'Auberge du thaï
pourtant les gendarmes vont bientôt s'en
rendre compte dans ce dossier il y a un
énorme problème
selon altobella George ourdin est mort
en juillet 1992
l'enquête a débuté en septembre 2003
plus de 10 ans après la mort de Georges
les faits serait donc prescrit dans ce
cas le dossier s'effondre personne ne
peut être poursuivi
les gendarmes tentent une ultime
vérification
alors il nous faut la datation des faits
ce qui est quand même principal pour
savoir si on travaille dans le temps de
la prescription ou pas si on prend les
témoignages dans leur ensemble
l'effet pouvait s'être déroulé entre
1991 et 1997 c'est trop large et il nous
faut trouver d'autres éléments et on va
avec des points de détails affiner au
maximum pour avoir
une fourchette la plus courte possible
finalement c'est une information a
priori anodine qui va apporter la
réponse
[Musique]
on sait que le corps après avoir été
incinéré a été transporté par Claude
dans un véhicule qui venait d'acquérir
on a vérifié partir de quel moment il
disposait de ce véhicule et la carte
grise a été à son nom à partir de
juillet 94 donc on sait forcément que
George Jourdain est mort au plus tard
vers le mois de février 94 on élimite on
est à un mois de la prescription on peut
dire que quand même capelleri est passé
à l'air un mois et demi près du crime
parfait
les autres protagonistes de la faire
Claude le fils d'altobella et Frank le
bonnet du village ont eux beaucoup plus
de chance l'effet de viol on n'a pas pu
établir
très précisément leur date le créneau de
leur commission mais on a pu quand même
savoir que c'était un intervenu
longtemps avant c'était d'ailleurs
plusieurs mois avant le décès de George
woderm et donc à partir de là on a pu on
a plus que constater le fait que l'effet
de viol était prescrit pour les faits de
complicité dans le parquet que le juge
d'instruction en considéré que l'emprise
qu'exerçait altobella capellerie sur les
sur ses proches
ne leur laissez plus un libre arbitre
suffisant qui aurait permis de retenir
la responsabilité il ne reste finalement
que alto Bella qui elle va devoir
répondre de la mort de George Jourdain
donc elle va être toute seule dans le
box de la cour d'assise pour répondre
des circonstances de la mort de George
Jourdain
alto Bella capellerie a-t-elle tué
George Jourdain ou s'agit-il d'un
sordide accident
les apparences joueraient-elles contre
l'aubergiste italienne autant de
questions auxquelles la justice va
devoir répondre
je rappelle quand même qu'on a pas de
cadavre que les aveu sont
très loin de la vérité très probablement
on a juste une certitude c'est qu'il est
mort mais on sait pas très bien comment
donc oui il y a un vrai enjeu il y a un
vrai jeu parce que si on l'écoute elle
n'a rien fait
7 décembre 2009 cours d'assises de
Montauban 15 ans après la mort de
Georges Jourdain alto Bella capellerie
comparé pour séquestration ayant
entraîné la mort lorsqu'elle entre dans
le box l'aubergiste n'a pas l'air d'une
femme dominatrice
elle a pas l'air
plus défaillante psychologiquement enfin
voilà c'est la dame qu'on peut croiser à
la boulangerie enfin voilà
c'est notre voisine en fait aussi ça qui
fait peur c'est une femme petite qui
semble avoir été bien malmené par la vie
et qui est prostré dans son box avec
quelques difficultés
d'élocutions
l'image qu'elle donne à l'audience ne
correspond pas à l'image que l'on a
d'elle dans le dossier elle se déforme
mais mollement et tout compte fait ne
semble pas vraiment être présente à
certains moments elle donne un peu cette
impression de ne pas être présente dans
le box et que ce procès se déroule un
peu loin d'elle altebella est interrogée
sur les faits en lui soumet les
différents témoignages qu'il accuse qui
l'accable même et elle tombait la répond
imperturbable
elle tombait la capellerie dans le
registre de dire tout le monde demande
sauf moi il y a une phrase qui reviendra
plusieurs reprises dans sa bouche quand
le président lui dit enfin Madame on dit
ceci de vous un tel dit ceci de vous un
tel dit ceci de vous la réponse c'est
les gens ils disent ça qui veulent cette
réponse la conique la famille de George
ourdin ne peut l'accepter elle a besoin
de savoir ce qui s'est réellement passé
comment Georges est mort leur avocate
tente alors de déstabiliser altobella de
manière anodine sournoise même elle
demande à l'italienne si elle a déjà eu
un chien à l'auberge et là elle me dit
oui oui un labrador je crois que c'est
labrador dans mon souvenir du bon mais
très bien il est devenu quoi le labrador
mais il est mort elle me dit il est mort
très bien et vous en avez fait quoi
votre chien
sous l'arbre puis c'était une évidence
on est allé enterré le chien sous
l'arbre et là vous l'avez donné au
cochon mais elle se décomposer cramé
dans la cheminée jeter dans les
poubelles et ça vous perturbe pas et là
silence radio rien
on voit que son chien finalement
ellitonné parce que pour elle c'était
une évidence d'aller l'enterrer
et Georges avec qui on vit pendant six
ans qui est quand même un être humain on
lui fait subir ce qu'on sait qu'il a
subi
altobella ne répond rien la
démonstration de l'avocate marque les
jurés de son côté l'avocat de
l'aubergiste lui soutient toujours la
thèse accidentelle et un accident un
soir de beuverie ou une bagarre ou une
dispute entrevrogne et au lieu de
décrocher le téléphone et d'appeler la
gendarmerie parce qu'on a eu peur on
s'est dit on fait disparaître le cadavre
si
l'accusé avait décroché son téléphone
pour appeler la gendarmerie il y avait
pas d'affaires
après seulement 1h30 de délibérer le
verdict tombe
altobella cappelleri l'italienne
Aucamville est reconnue coupable de
séquestration ayant entraîné la mort de
George ourdin elle est Cope de 15 ans de
prison
fidèle à son attitude tout au long du
procès
altobella encaisse le verdict sans
montrer la moindre émotion
l'année suivante en appel à Toulouse
alto Bella capellerie sera plus
lourdement condamné cinq années de
prison supplémentaires 20 ans
[Musique]
si la mémoire de George ourdin a pu être
retrouvé c'est grâce au travail
d'enquête des gendarmes parce que sinon
George Jourdain c'était quoi c'était un
homme qui les dernières années de sa vie
avait été réduit à l'état d'esclaves et
dont on était allé jusqu'à faire
disparaître le corps dans un conteneur
poubelle
alto Bella capellerie devrait pouvoir
demander une libération conditionnelle à
partir de 2018
[Musique]